Hey, pardon me sir I think you have the wrong car
You've emailed for an appointement 2 days in row
Tell me what's going on
I've never seen a case like this before
Twenty-three identities live in Kevin's body
Did something happen?
Open the door !
There's a flower on the pillows a flower in the bathroom
Like we're important
Who is that ? Maybe she can help us
We're here!
Don't worry
He knows what you're here for. He's not allowed to touch you
He knows that
My name's Hedwig
I have red socks
How old are you ?
Nine
The human brain is the most complex object in the universe
The only way we're getting out of here is if one of them decides to let us out
Aren't you the clever one ?
Hedwid, can you help us ?
Okay !
I have a window in my room
Maybe you could show us ?
Oh that's here !
Now it's closed, now it's open !
Did you think it was a real window ?
So you could leave ?
An individual with multiple personalities can change their body chemistry with their thoughts !
Someone's coming for you
What will happen when he unlocks the potential of his brain?
Ther is no limit to what he can become
Tonight is a sacred night
You will be in the presence of something greater
The world will understand now
The beast is real
He's done awful things to people and he'll do awfull things to you
Hey,pardon me sir I think you have the wrong car
What are we doing here ?
What the hell is going on ?
I was sent to get you for a reason
Open the door !
The's a flower on the pillows a flower in the bathroom
Like we're important
The only chance we have is if all three of us go crazy on this guy
Who is that ? Maybe she can help us
We're here !
Don't worry, he's not allowed to touch you
He knows what you're here for
He listens to me
My name's Hedwig
How old are you ?
Nine
I've never seen a case like this before
23 identities live in Kevin's body
Who are you ?
Help me get out of here Hedwig
Are you trying to trick me ? I'll tell on you
Aren't you the clever one ?
An individual with multiple personalities can change their body chemistry with their thoughts
Someone's coming for you
The beast
There's a man here, he abducted us and he's going to kill me
We're meant for something
Something horrible
The world will understand now
The beast is real
He's done awful things to people and he'll do awful things to you